Evet gençler, hızlıca bu üniteyi
halledeceğimizi söylemiştim. Şimdi
sırada öz ısı, ısı sağası gibi kavramlar
var. Bunları öğrendikten sonra hal
değişiminde bu kavramlar bizim ne
işimize yarayacak onları göreceğiz
ilerleyen derslerde. Hızlıca bu
kavramları ortaokulda gördüklerinizin
üzerine ekleyerek bir öğrenelim. Paraf
yayınlarının sağ olsun bize vermiş
olduğu bu PDF'lere deduva.com'dan
ulaşabilirsiniz. Onun üzerinden benim
önemli gördüğüm yerleri nasıl çiziyorsam
sizler de çizerek gerekli küçük
notlarınızı alarak ilerlemeniz daha
kolay, daha hızlı olur diye düşünüyorum.
Şimdi gelelim öz ısı, ısı sahası ve
sıcaklık değişimi arasındaki ilişkiye.
İlk olarak öz ısıyı bir hatırlayalım
seninle. Bir maddenin 1 gramının
sıcaklığını 1 s derece değiştirmek için
gerekli ısı miktarına öz ısı diyoruz.
Şimdi bu tanım inanılmaz böyle nasıl ne
yapmamız gerektiğini anlamadığımız bir
tanım. Böyle çok farklı değil mi? 1
gramını 1 S derece artırmak için,
değiştirmek için ne kadar ısı vermemiz
lazım? Yani elinde 1 gram suyun var. Sen
de ocağını açtın ve o su 20 S dereceydi.
21 S D olacak. 1 st d sıcaklığı artması
için o ocaktan ne kadar kalori veya ne
kadar jüük bir enerji aktarımı olacak?
Bunu tanımlayan bir kavram. Öz ısıyı
küçük C sembolü ile gösteriyoruz. Biz
bunu temel büyüklüklerde görmedik.
Öyleyse bu türetilmiş bir büyüklük. Öz
ısının birimini kalori/ gram x s d veya
jou/ kilogram x stig dce diye aklında
tutabilirsin. Aslında bu şimdi ezber
yaparken bizi üzecek bir durum. Şöyle
bir formül göreceğiz hal değişiminde. Q
= M, C ve delta T diye. Şimdi Q neydi?
Bizim için enerjiydi, ısıydı. Ve bunun
birimini j olarak tanımlamıştık. Kabul
mü? Evet. M neydi? Kütle demekti.
Kütleyi kilogram olarak tanımlamıştık. C
buradaki küçük C bizim için öz ısı
zaten. Delta T ne sevgili arkadaşım?
Sıcaklığındaki değişim. Sıcaklığı ne
diye ifade etmiştik? Ya Kelvin ya
santigrat derece. Ama buradaki birimler
hep santigrat derece olarak verildiği
için santigrat derece olarak yazıyorum.
Şimdi bu durumda ben öz ısıyı yalnız
bıraktığımda karşıda jou var. Bu komşuda
kim var? Kilogram ve santigrat derece
var. İşte sizin karşınıza gelen kavram
birimi böyle çekmiş oluyorsunuz. Yani
ezber yapmayacağız bize. Ya bu ne
demekti diye düşünmemize gerek kalmadan
şöyle hayal edeceğiz. Şu formülü
aklımızda tutacağız ki bir sonraki
derste uzun uzun bunu nasıl işleme
dökeceğimizi size anlatacağım. Ama bu
formülden giderek özının çekimini
yapabiliyoruz birimsel olarak. Bir
diğeri bize hani bir maddenin 1 gramını
1 st derece demişti ya o enerji miktarı
olarak tanımlamıştı ya. Bak enerji,
kütle ve sıcaklık değişimi. Hım. Demek
ki öz ısı aslında enerjiyle ilişkili,
kütleyle ilişkili, sıcaklık değişimi ile
ilişkili. Ona göre birimini
çekebiliyorum dedim. Özsı maddeler için
ayırt edici bir özelliktir. Ne demek
biliyor musun? Maddeleri tanımamıza
yarayan bir bilgi. Mesela bizim için TC
kimlik numaralarımız, bizim ayırt edici
özelliklerimiz. Çünkü her birimizin TC
kimlik numarası farklı veya parmak izi
sallıyorum. Bu öz ısıda maddeleri ayırt
etmemize yarayan yani maddenin ne
olduğunu anlamamıza yarayan ayırt edici
bir kimlik tanıması yapabileceğimiz
özellik. Öz ısı madde miktarına bağlı
değil. Yani ne demek istiyorum? 1 gram
suyun öz ısısıyla bir oda dolusu
tonlarca olan suyun öz ısısı aynı. Çünkü
aynı madde. Aynı maddeyse öz ısısı aynı.
Aynı öz kütle gibi düşünebilirsin. Fakat
öz ısı o kadar ayırt edici ki suyun öz
ısısıyla buzun öz ısısı birbirinden
farklı veya su buharının öz ısısı
birbirinden farklı ki birazdan şu
tabloda göreceğiz zaten. Suyun öz ısısı
1 kalori/ gr s derecedir. 1 gram suyun
sıcaklığının 1 stig değiştirmek için
ihtiyaç duyduğumuz ısı değeri bir kalori
olarak tanımlandı. Şimdi şöyle bir
bakalım. Yani farklı birimlerle ifade
edersek kalori böl gram sant derece diye
ifade edersek jou/ kilogram s derece
diye ifade edersek diye ayrı ayrı
tanımlanmış. Burada ezbere bilmen
gereken hiçbir şey yok. Sadece öz ısının
su birken buzun 050 buharın 050 demirin
011 çeliğin 012 tahta bakır git gide
azaldı. Her madde için neredeyse şu buz
ve buhar bizim için bir tık bu
genellemeden ayrı tutulabilir ama her
madde için yani su, demir, çelik, tahta,
bakır neyi görüyoruz? İstersek şuradan
da bakabiliriz. Öz ısı değerlerinin
farklı olduğunu görüyoruz. Öz ısısı en
büyük maddelerden biri su. Bu ne demek?
Suyun öz ısısının büyük olması, suyun
sıcaklığının 1 st derece değişmesi için
çok daha fazla enerji gerektirdiğini
söyler. Hatta şimdilik aklında kalması
gereken bir bilgi vereyim. Günlük
hayatta şunu kullanırız. Mesela deriz ki
denizler karalara göre daha geç ısınır,
daha geç soğur. Sebebi ne biliyor musun?
Denizlerdeki suyun öz ısısının büyük
olması. öz ısısı büyük olduğu için daha
geç ısınıyor, daha geç soğuyor. Yani
onun sıcaklığını artırmamız için gereken
enerji miktarı çok daha fazla diye
aklında tutabilirsin. Şimdi gelelim ısı
sırası kavramına. Isı sığası da bir
madde ya da cismin sıcaklığını 1 st
derece değiştirmek için gerekli olan ısı
enerjisini olarak tanımlanıyor. E hocam
yukarıdakinden farkı ne? Özsı da
aynıydı. Öz ısıyı konuşurken şu bilginin
yanına bir de 1 gram demiştik. Yani
orada kütleyi de ifade etmiştik. Burada
ısı sığası dediğimiz kavramı büyük C
harfi ile gösteriyoruz ve kütle ve öz
ısının çarpımı olarak ifade ediyoruz.
Isı sahası maddenin cinsine ve miktarına
bağlıdır ama öz ısı değildi hatırlarsan.
Öz ısı maddenin miktarından bağımsızdı.
Ayırt edici bir özellik değil. He öz ısı
ayırt edici ısı sahası ayırt edici
değil. Özsı madde miktarına bağlı değil.
Fakat ısısı madde miktarına bağlı. Hani
demiştim ya bir bardak suyla bir oda
dolusu suyun öz ısısı aynı diye. Isı
sahası sana sorsam bizim için ısı sahası
kütleyile doğru orantılı olduğundan,
madde miktarına bağlı olduğundan bir oda
dolusu suyun ısı sahası kesinlikle daha
fazladır diyeceğiz. Isı sahasını büyük C
ile gösterdik. Kalori/ Sig Dou/ S D
olarak tanımlarız. Daha yeniki yazdığım
formülden tekrar gideceğim. Q = MC delta
T diye bir formül var. Ayrıntılarını bir
sonraki derste konuşacağım. Fakat şimdi
bakıyorum. MC yani QTE ile öz ısının
çarpımı ısı sağası demekti ya. Bak
arkadaşım buna jou de. Buna da santigrat
derecede. Bu durumda ısı sığası diye
tanımladığımız m ve c'yi çarptığımızda
büyük c'ye ulaştığımız bu kavram jou/ d
veya ısının bir diğer birimi kaloriydi.
Kalori/ stig diye ifade edilir dedik ve
ısı sığasını kütle ve öz ısının
çarpımıyla olduğunu tanımlamış olduk.
Şimdi gelelim şu grafiği okumaya.
Grafiklerden hepimiz korkuyoruz fakat
grafikte bilmemiz gereken şey bu
değişkenler ne? Bana ne grafiği
verilmiş? Isı sağ ve kütle. Isı sağını
yazdırdığım MC demekti. Kütle neydi? M
demekti. Şimdi bu grafiğin eğimine
bakacağım. Ya da elimde MC ve M
değerleri varsa ben bunları biliyorsam
mesela sana desem ki ısı
sı. Isı sırası MC'si 10 kütlesi 2 ise
sen bana buradan neyi bulabilirsin
hocam? Tabii ki öz ısısını bulurum. Onu
2'ye bölerim. öz ısı değerinin 5
olduğunu bulmuş olurum. Çünkü kütlenin 2
olduğunu verdim. İşte bu yüzden ne
diyoruz? Böyle bir grafik verilirse ısı
sığasını kütleye bölerek o cismin öz ısı
değerine ulaşabiliyoruz. Fakat bu
dediğim gibi değişkenlerin ne olduğuna
göre değişir. Yani ezber yapmayacaksın.
Bu grafikleri gördün mü? Ya ben eğim mi
yapacaktım ya da bu grafiğin eğimi şunu
mu veriyordu? Belki adam ne yapacak sana
soruda? Kütleyi buraya yazacak. Buraya
ısı sahası yazacak. Sen hangi
değişkenlerin hangi değerde olduğunu
bulup rahatlıkla bize cevabı
verebileceksin. Şimdi öz ısı C'ydi. Isı
sağ MC'ydi. Hemen örneğimize baktık.
Diyor ki bunlarla ilgili hangileri
doğrudur? Isı sahası maddeler için ayırt
edici bir özelliktir. Isı sahası MC
demekti. Kütleye bağlıydı. ayırt edici
bir özellik değildi. Sadece öz ısı ayırt
ediciydi. Öz ısısı bilinen bir maddenin
hangi madde olduğu anlaşılabilir. Çünkü
ne dedik? Bizim için ayırt edici yani
kimlik ataması yapabiliyoruz dedik.
Isısı madde miktarına bağlıdır. Çünkü
kütle ile ilişkilendirmiştik. Kabul
ettik. Öz ısı madde miktarına bağlı
değildir. Yani 1 gram suyunda 1 ton
suyunda öz ısısı aynı demiştik.
Dolayısıyla bunu da kabul ettik. 2, 3 ve
4. öncüllerimiz doğru verilmiştir dedik.
Basitçe bunu da halletmiş olduk. Öz ısı
maddenin sıcaklığında oluşabilecek
değişmelere karşı direnme özelliği
olarak düşünebilir. Suyun öz ısısı fazla
olduğu için daha geç ısınıyor, daha geç
soğuyordu. Su öz ısısı yüksek bir
maddedir. Bu nedenle ısıtma ve soğutma
sıvısı olarak birçok yerde su
kullanılır. Mesela aranızda arabayla
ilgilenen arkadaşlar varsa o
radyatörlerde bir su dolanıyor. O su
dolanmasının sebebi neden su
kullanıyoruz? Suyun öz ısısı büyük.
Isıtma ve soğutma
sistemlerinde ne dedik? Bizim için bu
direnme özelliği daha fazla olacağından
suyu kullanmamız daha sağlıklı olur diye
yorumlayabildik. Şimdi devam edelim. KLM
cisimlerini vermiş. Kaç gram olduğunu,
hangi madde olduğunu vermiş. Diyor ki bu
maddeleri yukarıdaki gibi tanımladık. Bu
maddelerin öz ısılarını 042 012 1 olarak
tanımladı. Bu maddelerin ısı sığalarını
yani diyor ki ben sana burada nesini
verdim? Öz ısılarını. Öz ısılarını
verdim. Burada nelerini verdim diyor.
Geldim sana kütlelerini verdim. Şimdi de
senden ne istiyorum? Isı sığası. Isı
sığası neydi? Hemen yazdır. M x C
demekti. K'nın M'i ne kadar sevgili
arkadaşım? 400 gr. C'si ne kadar? Yani
öz ısısı ne kadar? 042. Tamam. Şöyle
dursun. L''yi yazıyorum. Kütlesi 300 gr.
Öz ısısı
012. Geldim. M'yi yazıyorum. M'nin 100
gram olduğunu biliyorum. Bir öz ısıya
sahip olduğunu biliyorum. Çarptım 100
geldi. Buraya geldim. Şununla şu
birbirlerini sadeleştirdi. Yani 12/100
olarak yazdım aslında. Oradaki sıfırları
sadeleştirdim. 30'la 12'yi çarptım. 360
değerine ulaştım. Şurada da şunları
sadeleştirdim. 42/100 olarak da
yazabilirsin. 42 ile 4'ü çarp. 4 x 2 8 4
x 4 16 bir tane de 0 ekle. Bu durumda
zaten şöyle yapabilirsin. Hiç çarpma
işlemi yapma. Ya hocam K'nın kütlesi
fazla. Öz ısısı da aralarından en büyük.
O zaman K'nın ısı sağası en büyük
olacak. Sonra L. Soru bitti. K L M hangi
seçenekte verildi? Buraya kadar gelip de
yanlış işaretlemeyi istemiyorum. K'nın
öz ısısı özür dilerim ısısası en büyük.
Sonra L, sonra M diye ifade ettik.
Bitirdik. Şimdi öz ısıyı gördük. Isı
sısını gördük. Sıra geldi sıcaklık
değişimine. Sıcaklık değişimi ne? Benim
son sıcaklığımla ilk sıcaklığımın
arasındaki farkı
tanımlamakta. Hemen bakalım. Bir
örneğimiz var. İlk sıcaklık ve son
sıcaklıklar verilmiş ve ÖSYM de çıkmış
bir soru. Olaya gel. Ne kadar kolay
olduğunu gör. Yukarıdaki çizelgede biz
sana maddeleri verdik. Aşağıdakilerden
hangileri doğrudur diyor. M'nin
sıcaklığı 7 s derece azalmıştır.
Bakalım. M + 1 -8 olmuş. Bir kere azaldı
değil mi? Artıdan eksiye geçti. +1'den
-8'e giderken sevgili arkadaşım arada
bir sayı doğrusu olarak hayal et. Çünkü
skaler bir durumdasın. Skaler bir
sahadasın aslında. + 1'den sayı
doğrusunda -8'e gitmek için ne kadarlık
bir azalma var? 9 S derecelik A'yı
eledim. B'ye geldim. K'nın sıcaklığı 3 S
D artı dedi. -3'ten +3'e. Sayı doğrusunu
düşürdüm. -3'ten 0'a geldin. 0'dan 3'e
gittin. + 6 derecelik bir artış var
dedin. B'yi eledin. C'ye baktın. P'nin
sıcaklığı 1 S D azaldı. P
-5'ten +4'e yine +9'luk bir artış var
gitti. N'nin sıcaklığı 6 S D artmıştır.
N'ye geldim. -8'den -2'ye sayı
doğrusunda 0a yaklaştıkça değerimiz
artıyordu. Negatiften 0'a. Yani -8 daha
küçük -2'ye göre. Dolayısıyla 6
derecelik bir artış var. Evet, bunu
kabul ettim. Bir de E'yi okuyayım.
Kendimi garantiye alayım. L''nin
sıcaklığı 7° artmıştır dedi. Bir kere L
ne oldu? + 3'ten -4'e bir kere azaldı.
-7 azalma var. O yüzden bunu da elemiş
olduk. Sıcaklık değişimi. Son sıcaklığa
baktım. İlk sıcaklığa baktım. Aradaki
farkı konuşmuş oldum. Bitirdim. Şimdi
bunlar arasında ne gibi bir ilişki
kuracağız burada? Başlıyoruz seninle bu
formüllere. Isı alan ya da veren
maddelerde meydana gelen
değişikliklerden biri sıcaklık değişimi.
Her zaman sıcaklık değişimi olmayacak ki
hal değişimini de göreceğiz seninle.
Diğerleri neymiş zaten? Hal değişimi ve
genleşme durumuymuş. Ben eğer ki
dışarıdan ısı alıyorsam ve hal
değiştirme genleşme yaşamıyorsam genelde
sıcaklığım artıyor. Eğer ki dışarıya ısı
veriyorsam bu durumda da genelde
sıcaklığım azalıyor. Isı alan maddelerin
taneciklerinin titreşim hareketi ya da
kinetik enerjileri artar. Bu da
sıcaklığın artması demektir. Veya
verdiysek titreşimimiz, kinetik
enerjimiz azaldı, sıcaklığımız azaldı
demek. Matematiksel modeli Q = MC delta
T olarak tanımladık. Q neydi? Isıydı.
Yani bu farklı sıcaklıktaki maddeler
arasında aktarılan enerjiydi. Q'yu
yazdım. M neydi? Kütleydi. C neydi? Öz
ısıydı. Eğer ki M ve C'yi çarparsak yani
kütle ve öz ısıyı çarparsak ısı sığası
dediğimiz bu kavramı gördük. Delta T ne
demek? Delta fark demek. Sıcaklıktaki
değişim olarak ifade etmiş olduk. Bunu
da zaten sana tablo olarak belirttik.
Sai birimi kütlenin neydi? kilogram
farklı bir birim olarak bazı sorularda
gram olarak kullanabilirsin. Öz jou/
kilogram kelvin veya kalori böl gram
sant derece. Artık sana soruda verilen o
birimlere göre hareket edeceksin.
Sıcaklık değişimi kelvin veya santigrat
derece olarak ele alınabilir dedik.
Sıdaki birimi kelvin unutmak yok.
aktarılan ısı Q dediğimiz enerjiydi.
Joule olarak tanımlanmıştı Sı unit birim
sisteminde. Başka bir birim olarak
kalori olarak da günlük hayatta bunu
gözlemleyebiliriz dedik. Bu arada bu
formülü kodlamak isterseniz genelde kel
macit diye aklımızda tutuyoruz.
Haberiniz olsun. Sizin de beğendiyseniz
kullanabilirsiniz. Ya da farklı
kodlamalarınız varsa yorumlara
yazabilirsiniz sevgili arkadaşlar. Oy
yoruldum. Bu arada böyle bir tık da
dinlenelim istiyorum. Siz benden kimi
zaman rehberlik videoları istiyorsunuz.
Ayrı bir rehberlik videosu yapmalı mıyım
emin değilim. Çünkü genelde ders
arasında da sizlerle konuşmaya gayret
ediyorum. Bu arada da arka planda
gerçekten ciddi anlamda çok böyle
deneyler üzerinde, yeni müfredat
üzerinde, seneye size yapacağım
sürprizli ders anlatımları üzerinde
ciddi çalışmalar yapıyorum arkadaşlar.
Umarım önümüzdeki liseyi tamamlama
sürecini birlikte başarıyla, keyifle
atlatırız. Biliyorum lise biraz böyle
yeni müfredatın da getirdiği etkiyle
biraz bizi sıkıntıya soktu. Ama
inanıyorum ki önümüzdeki süreçlerde hem
birbirimize alışacağız, hem derslere
alışacağız, hem soru çözmeye alışacağız,
atlatacağız. Buna inanıyorum. Siz
sıkıntılarınızı bana yazmaktan
çekinmeyin. Gerek Instagram'dan yazan
arkadaşlarınız var, gerek burada
yorumlara yazan arkadaşlarınız var. Siz
bana yazın. Ben de o sizin yazdıklarınız
doğrultusunda nasıl içerikler
üretmeliyim onları tamamlamış olayım.
Seneye çok güzel sürpriz içerikler var.
O yüzden lütfen kanala abone olarak,
videoları beğenerek izleyin arkadaşlar
ki beni motive edebileceğiniz tek kısım
burası. O yüzden sizin desteklerinizi
bekliyorum. Emeklerimi göz ardı
etmeyeceğinizi gerçekten dört gözde
bekliyorum sevgili arkadaşlar. Şimdi
biraz konuştuk mola da vermiş olduğum.
Dersleri uzatmayın diyorsunuz. Dersi
uzatmıyorum ama böyle bazı konuların
içeriği çok yoğun olduğu için böyle hep
ders ders gibi oluyor. O da beni
yoruyor. Sizi de yoruyordur eminim. O
yüzden siz de mola vererek
izleyebilirsiniz. Şimdi örnek 10'la
devam edelim. Aynı maddeden yapılmış,
aynı maddeden yapıldıysa bir kere öz
ısılar aynı. Maddelerin ayırt edici bir
özelliği kalmadı, değil mi? Hepsinin
aynı maddeden yapıldığını gördük. KLM
cisimlerinin kütleleri sırasıyla m 2m 3m
olarak verilmiş. Her birinin eşit
miktarda ısı almasını sağlıyoruz.
Cisimlerin sıcaklık değişimlerini konuş
bana dedi. Şimdi formülümüz neydi? Kel
mac. Şimdi aynı maddeden dediği için öz
ısıları her birinin aynı. Tamam mı?
Sonra bana bir şey daha dedi. Dikkat et.
Her birine eşit miktarda ısı veriyoruz.
Yani her birine 100 kalori veya 100 J
ısı veriyoruz. Şimdi bunlar aynıysa
elimde kalanlar ne? M ve delta T. Bunlar
da denklemin aynı kısmındalar değil mi?
Bu durumda bunların ters orantılı
olduğunu söylersin. Yani dersin ki hocam
kütlesi büyük olanın sıcaklık değişimi
daha az olacak. Şey gibi hayal etmeni
istiyorum. Elimde bir bir bardak su var.
Bir de 2 Lre su var. Ben aynı ocağa
koydum. Aynı miktarda enerji veriyorum.
Hangisi daha kolay sıcaklığını artırır?
Daha az miktarda kütlesi olan. Değil mi?
İşte o formül. Bu formül sevgili
arkadaşım. ters orantı ilişkisi buradan
gelmekte. Öyleyse ne diyeceksin? Hocam
bana m, 2m, 3m diye verdin. Kütlesi
fazla olanın yani atıyorum elimde 1 L, 2
L, 5 L su var ve ben aynı ısıtıcıyla
ısıtıyorum. Aynı enerjiyi aktarıyorum. O
zaman daha fazla miktarda su olanın
sıcaklık değişimi daha az olacak.
Öyleyse kütlesi fazla olan M'di. M'nin
sıcaklık değişimi en az olan sonra L.
Cevabım E seçeneği. Bu kadar basit bir
yorumla halledebilirsiniz. Şayet şu
kısımda hocam ben doğru orantı, ters
orantıda sıkıntı yaşıyorum. Bunları daha
ayrıntılı konuşalım derseniz muhakkak
yorumlara yazın. Dediğim gibi bu üniteyi
hızlıca bitirin. Sonra sizin
takıldığınız yerler üzerinden tekrarlar
yapmayı hedefliyorum. Böyle matematiksel
formülleri konuşurken sıkıntı
yaşıyorsanız lütfen yazın. Tamam mı? Ben
de ona göre notlarımı alayım. Örnek 11
ne dedi? Saf maddeden yapılmış katı K
cismine Q kadar enerji verildiğinde
sıcaklığı 3T'den 5T'ye çıkıyor. Yani
sıcaklığında ne kadar bir değişim var?
2T'lik. Şimdi o zaman hemen bir yazalım.
Q MC delta T'si 2T kadar. Süper. Q kadar
daha ısı verirsek sıcaklığı 7T'ye çıkar.
Yani diyor ki sen Q'da 2T'lik bir
sıcaklık değişimi yapıyorsan bir Q daha
verdin. 2Q olsun. O zaman MC 4T kadar
bir değişim olacak değil mi? Şunu şöyle
yapayım. Hepsini görün. 4T kadarlık bir
değişim olacak. Bu durumda sevgili
arkadaşım ilk baştaki sıcaklığım 3T'ydi.
4T kadar değişim olduğunda son
sıcaklığım 7T oldu. Ya da hocam hiç öyle
yapma. Normalde bana Q kadar bir enerji
verdiğinde 3'ten 5'e çıktıysam bir Q
daha 2 daha gitti. O zaman 7T'ye geldim
diye 1inci öncülü kabul edebilirsin.
Başlangıçta Q kadar ısı kaybetseydi. Bak
şimdi ısı aldığım için dışarıdan
sıcaklığım arttı. 3'ten 5'e çıktım. Q
kadar enerji verseydim sıcaklığım aynı
miktarda azalacaktı. İlk baştaki enerjim
3T. 2 daha azalttın. O zaman ne olacak?
T olacaktı. Bana demiş ki 2T olur.
Hayır. Sıcaklığımdaki değişim miktarı 2
olur. Fakat son sıcaklığım ne olur? 2
birim azaldı. 3'ten 2 birim azalttığım
için tare olurdu. 2'yi eledik. 3.
Başlangıçta cismin kütlesi 2 katı
olsaydı son sıcaklığı 4T olurdu. Çok
güzel bir soru. İyi takip et. Q = MC 2T
olarak yazmıştık. Şimdi sen bunu 2m
yaparsan kütlen iki katına çıktığı için
sıcaklığın yarısına kadar değişecekti.
Doğru mu? Çünkü kütle ve sıcaklık
değişimi ters orantılıydı. Ne kadar
fazla kütlemiz olursa sıcaklık
değişimimiz o kadar az oluyordu. Harika.
Bu durumda benim ilk sıcaklığım 3T'di
sevgili arkadaşım. 1T kadarlık değişim
olacak artık. 3T 4T olur dedim. 1 ve 3ün
öncülerin doğru geldi. Harika bir soru.
Anlamadıysan lütfen bir durdur, sil.
Kendin bir çözmeye çalış. Sen nasıl
yorumluyorsun? Ben neye dikkat ederek
yorumluyorum? Bu ikisi arasında bir
ayrım yap, analiz yap. Sizlerden ricamız
binlerce soru çözmeniz değil, bir tane
soruyu anlayarak çözmeniz. O yüzden
biraz zaman ayırmanız lazım arkadaşlar.
Şunu görüyorum. Hocam ben ders anlıyorum
soru çözemiyorum. Elbette hemen çat diye
bütün soruları full çekmenizi
beklemiyoruz ama siz fiziğe ne kadar
zaman ayırırsanız, ne kadar pratik
yaparsanız ve ne kadar sabırlı olursanız
fizikte o kadar yol kat edersiniz.
Lütfen bunu unutmayın. Zaman içerisinde
hepsini birlikte halletmiş olacağız. 12.
örnek ne demiş? KLM buz parçalarının
kütle, ilk sıcaklık ve son sıcaklık
değerlerini verdi. Bak elimde m var.
Sıcaklık farkı var. Yani delta T'yi
bulurum. Hepsi de buz olduğu için C'leri
de aynı. Benden neyi istedi? Q'larını.
Şimdi o zaman seninle artık Q'larını
yazabiliriz. Formül. Bir tane formül
öğrendik. MC delta T. M'in 150 C'si C.
Hiç önemli değil. Yazmak zorunda
değilsin. Çünkü benden büyüktür küçüktür
sıralaması istemiş. Direkt çat diye. Q
kaçtır diye sormamış. Delta T ne?
-30'dan -20'ye. Ne kadarlık bir delta T
söz konusu? Delta t'yi yazmak için t son
- t ilk diye yazacaktık. -20. Bak şimdi
yazıyorum dikkat et. -20 - formülde var.
-30. Bu durumda burası artı olur.
Parantezden çıkar ve 10 derecelik bir
sıcaklık değişimi söz konusu. Sayı
doğrusunu ayar et. -30'dan -20'ye
geldin. 10 derecelik bir değişim söz
konusu. Süper. L''yi yazdın. Kütlen
aynı. Öz aynı. -30'dan -10'a sayı
doğrusunu hayal ettiğin 20 derecelik bir
fark söz konusu. Buraya geldin 200. C
aynı -30'dan -10'a yine 20°. O zaman
sevgili arkadaşım şu C'ler hepsinde
aynı. Bak şuradaki sıfırlarla da
uğraşma. Şunları da ele. 15 x 1'den 15Q
olsun. Oran orantı yap. Yani 15 x 2'den
30Q kadar enerjin olsun. 20 x 2'den 40Q
gelir. Bu durumda M'nin enerjisi en
fazla. Yani M'ye aktarılan ısı en fazla
değerde. Sonra L, sonra K. M, L, K.
Cevabım A seçeneği. Umarım çarpımlarda
bir hata yapmamışımdır. Sen de kontrol
et. Bir hatan varsa beni kesinlikle
uyar. Geçenlerde hatta böyle yazınca bir
öğrenci yazmış. Hocam bizi uyar
diyorsunuz. Zaten biz biliyorsak sizi
neden işte izliyor olalım falan diye
böyle. Arkadaşlar insanoğluyuz. A, B, C
diye sıralarım. giderim CBA diye
yazarım. Yani böyle bir dikkat hatası
olursa siz dikkatli dinleyin. Beni
uyarın istiyorum. Yoksa benim bütün
dediklerimi onaylayacak bilgiye sahip
olun demiyorum. Bazı öyle kötü demeyeyim
de olumsuz yorum yazan arkadaşlar
oluyor. Aslında her zaman bizi övmek
zorunda değilsiniz. Yani her zaman iyi
bir yorum yazmak zorunda değilsiniz. Ama
olumsuz bir yorum yazarken de üslubumuza
dikkat etmeliyiz. Karşıdakinin sana
ücretsiz eğitim veren bir öğretmen
olduğunu baz alarak yapıcı eleştiriler
yapmalıyız. Dediğim gibi dil üslup her
şeyden önemli arkadaşlar. Yoksa olumsuz
şeyler de yazmalısınız ki ben de kendimi
geliştireyim. Her zaman alkış alkış
olmaz yani değil mi? Biraz da beni
eleştirin. Ben de kendimi
iyileştirebileyim ama dilimiz önemli.
Buradan da o arkadaşımıza selam olsun.
Bir tane ÖSYM benzeri bir sorumuz var.
Çıkmış soruların ne kadar basit olduğunu
anlamanız için böyle PDF'lerde bunları
görüyorsunuz. Hava sıcaklığının deniz
suyu sıcaklığından yüksek olduğu bir yaz
günü. Akdeniz sahilinde deniz kenarında
oynamakta olan bir çocuk denizden bir
kova su aldı. Hava daha sıcak. Mesela
diyelim ki hava sıcaklığımız ne olsun? O
kadar yanıyoruz. 40 Sig D olsun hava.
Deniz suyu sıcaklığından daha yüksekmiş.
Denizimizde genelde denize girdiğimizde
biraz üşürüz ya. O da 30 S dce olsun.
Tamam mı? Yazdık. Deniz suyunun
homojenin olduğu bilindiğine göre deniz
suyu ve kovadaki su ile ilgili. Hım.
Şimdi biz kovayı aldık sevgili
arkadaşım. Normalde 30 Sig dereceydi
fakat havanın 40 olduğunu biliyorsun. Ve
neyi biliyorsun? Bizim için sıcaklık
farkı söz konusuysa kesinlikle enerji
aktarımı söz konusu. Hava bu kovadaki
suyumuzu ısıtacak değil mi? Isı
aktaracak. Sıcaklığını artıracak. Süper.
Bir kova su aldığı anda kovadaki suyun
öz ısısı denizdeki suyun öz ısısına
eşittir. İlk o anda aynı maddeden
bahsediyorsun. Öz ısı da maddeler için
ayırt edici bir özellikti. Evet. O zaman
dedim öz ısıları eşittir. Sıkıntı yok.
Yani özellikle bu tarz soruları okurken
lütfen sözellerini kendinize
hatırlatmaya çalışın. Bazen karışıklık
yaşayabiliyoruz ama eminim kaldırma
kuvvetinden sonra daha sevdiğiniz bir
konu olmuştur. Çok çok daha sözel olduğu
için. Kovadaki suyun ısı sığası. Isı
sahası neydi? m x C demekti. Denizdeki
suyun ısı sahasına eşittir. Hadi oradan
denizdeki suyun kütlesini hayal et. Bir
de kovadaki suyun kütlesini. Dolayısıyla
kovadaki suyun ısı sahası denizdeki
suyun ısı sahasından kesinlikle daha
azdı. 2'yi eledi. Bak hemen 2'yi ele.
Bir kesin doğru. O zaman şu da gitti.
3'e bakacağız. Kısa bir süre sonra
kovadaki suyun sıcaklığı deniz suyunun
sıcaklığına göre daha fazla artacaktır
hocam. Çünkü daha az miktarda. Yani
kütlesi daha az olduğu için hava tüm
denizlideki suyu ısıtamayacak.
Sıcaklığını hemen artıramayacak ama
kovadaki suyu daha kolay bir şekilde
sıcaklığını artırmış olacak. 3'ü de
kabul ettim. Doğru cevabım D seçeneği
geldi. Şimdi burada yine bir tane bir
grafik var. Grafikten korkmuyoruz. Bana
sıcaklığı vermiş. Yani T, verilen ısı
yani Q. Q ve T arasında nasıl bir ilişki
kurmuştuk seninle? Q = MC delta T. Yani
diyelim ki T'si 5 olsun. Q'su da 10
olsun. Q'yu biliyorsun 10.
Sıcaklığındaki değişim 0'dan 5'e 5. O
zaman sen hangi kavrama ulaşırsın bu
grafikten? Hocam Isı sahası kavramına
ulaşırım. Dolayısıyla yeter ki bana
grafikteki bu değişkenlerin ne olduğu
verilsin. O değer verilsin. Ben hemen
çat diye formülden yazarım. Ama sana
desem ki arkadaşlar eğim karşı bölü
komşu demek. Yok işte tanjantını
alacaksın. Bunun için tabii ki de
merkezde tet İlan hocamın kanalına bir
başvur. Her türlü işte tanjantını
alacaksın. Karşıda sıcaklık var. Verilen
ısı 1/ ısısı sı. Şunu yazınca öğrenci
korkuyor ve sevmiyor grafikleri. Ama
buradan grafikten alıp sanki bulmaca
gibi yerine yazdığında ısı sığası
kavramına yani büyük C kavramına
ulaştığımızı çok net görmüş oluyorsun.
Hiç ezber yapmana gerek yok. Bak
sıcaklık var. verilen ısı değeri var.
Senden istediğin bu KLM cisimlerinin ısı
sığaralarını kıyasla. Bak ne yapayım?
Hemen hop geleyim şuraya 10 diyeyim.
Kendim sayı doğrusundan değer veriyorum.
1 2 5 olsun diyeyim. Tamam mı? K için
yazıyorum. Q'su 10'muş. Verilen ısı.
MC'sini bilmiyorum. Büyük C. Hatta ona
CK yazalım. CK deyince de coğrafyanın
kodları oldu. Büyük C yazdım. Yani ısı
sahasını yazdım. MC değerini sıcaklık
değişimi K'nın ne oldu? 0'dan 5'e 5
kadar oldu. L için yazalım. Isısının 10
olduğunu söyledik. Ne kadarlık bir
sıcaklığında değişim var? 2 birimlik. M
için yazıyorum sevgili arkadaşım. 10 cm
yazdım. Isı sığası ne kadarlık bir
değişim var? 1 birim. O zaman artık bana
ısı sağlarını yazabilirsin. Dersin ki
hocam 5 ile 2'yi çarpayım 10 etsin. 2
ile 5'i çarpayım 10 etsin. 1 ile 10'u
çarpayım 10 etsin. Bu durumda M'nin ısı
sırası L''den o da K'dan daha büyüktür.
Bak aynı şeyi bulmuş oldun. Ezber yapma.
Ay yok eğimi neyi veriyordu? 1/ bilmem
ne miydi? Onun büyüğü o küçük mü
demekti? Asla kafanı karıştırma. Basitçe
böyle halledebilirsin. Demek ki bana
böyle bir grafik verilirse ısı sahasını
bulabilirim. Hemen bakalım. Özdeş
ısıtıcılarla t süre ısıtılan eşit
kütleli ikisi de m kadarmış. KL saf
sıvılarının öz ısıları sırasıyla C'ye
2C'ymiş. Isı sağlarını biliyoruz artık.
Buna göre sıvıların sıcaklık zaman
grafiği aşağıdakilerden hangisi gibi
olabilir? dedi sevgili arkadaşım. T süre
özdeş ısıtıcıyla ısıttım. O zaman Q
kadar enerji verdim. İkisine de K için
yazıyorum. K MC kadar. Buna delta TK
diyelim. L için yapalım. Aynı ısıyı
vereceğiz. 2mc oldu. Değil mi? Çarptım.
M ile 2C'yi çarptım. 2'yi başa aldım.
2mc geldi. Buna da delta T L diyelim.
Sevgili arkadaşım o zaman izin verirsen
ben buraya T2T kadar değişim olursa
burada T kadar değişir der miyim? Yani
şöyle düşün. ısı sahası büyük olduğu
için, madde miktarı büyük olduğu için
öyle hayalet. Hani daha fazla bir su var
elimde. Onun sıcaklık değişimi daha az
oluyordu. Ha hocam demek ki aslında
L''deki sıcaklık değişiminin az olduğu
bir grafiğe ihtiyacımız var ve bunun
oranının da 2'ye 1 olmasını bekliyorum.
Hazır mısın? K 3 birim değişmiş. L 1
birim değişmiş. 3'e 1 bir oran var. Bu
olamaz. K 0'dan 3'e 3 birim değişmiş. L
T'den 2T'ye 1 birim değişmiş. Yine bir 3
birimlik oranlar. Olmaz. Geldin bak.
Zaman sıcaklık diyor. K'ya bak. T'den
3T'ye 2T kadar değişti. L''ye bak 2T'den
3T'ye T kadar değişti. Evet bu olabilir.
Çünkü ben zaten böyle bulmuştum. Bir
daha devam ediyorum. kt kadar değişir. L
3T dedi gitti.
L 1T değişti. K da 1T değişti. Aynı
ısıda, aynı sıcaklık değişimine sahipse
aynı ısı sahası olacak. Ama gördük ki
soruda verilen ısı sağları 1e 2
oranındaydı. Isı sahası büyük olan
sıcaklık değişimi daha az olacak. Demek
ki ısı sahası ile sıcaklık değişimimiz
de ters orantılı. Zaten cevabım her
türlü C seçeneği geldi. Güzelce
hallettik. Bu örneğimize baktık. KL
maddelerinin sıcaklık verilen ısı
grafiği sıcaklık T ısı Q verdi hepsini
benden istediğine ısı saz ya kardeşim
grafikten çekip formüle yazacaksın K
için yazıyorum ne kadar bir ısı verildi
2Q MC'sini yani CK'sını yani ısı sıını
bilmiyorum onu soruyorsun ne kadar bir
sıcaklıkta değişim var 0'dan 2T'ye 2T
kadar L için yazdır bana hocam L'de Bak
0'dan yine 2Q'ya geldi. Fakat ne oldu
burada? Demek ki L dışarıya ısı verdi.
Hiçbir problem yok. Sıcaklık değişimi ne
kadar? T kadar. Cl yazdın. Bu durumda
bak şimdi taraf tarafa oran yapalım
seninle. Ya da şöyle yap. Şuradaki 2 ile
şu 2'yi sadeleştir. Şu qile bu qitsin. T
ile bu gitsin. Yukarıda 1 kaldı. Aşağıda
2 kaldı. Demek ki K ve L''nin ısı
sağlarını oranlarsak cevabımız 1/2
geliyormuş dedik. Soruyu bitirdik.
İstersen bu oran yapmakta sıkıntı
yaşıyorsan yerine bir sayı ver. Sayılara
göre değerini biç. Yine aynı şekilde 1/2
değerini bulmuş olacaksın. 1/2 deyince
yani L''nin ısı sırası daha büyüktür
deyince ne anlamam lazım? Isı sığası
yani büyükçe ne kadar büyükse sıcaklık
değişimi o kadar az olacak. Bak, aynı
enerji miktarında L''deki sıcaklık
değişimi 1 birim, K'daki sıcaklık
değişimi 2 birim. Yani K'nın ısı A'sı
L''nin ısı sağasının yarısı kadar olsun.
Çünkü bir ters orantı söz konusuydu.
Direkt böyle de
cevaplayabilirsin sanırım. Son sayfa.
Sonra hal değişimine başlıyoruz yine.
Hadi iyisiniz. 40 dakikaya geçmeden
dersimizi tamamlamış olacağız. Şöyle bir
derin nefes alın. Son iki soruya
kendinizi iyi verin. Vallahi formülde
yerine yazıyoruz. Başka hiçbir şey
yapmıyoruz. Q = MC delta değil. Başka
yaptığımız bir şey yok. Sıcaklık verdi
T. ısıyı verdi, Q. Öz ısılarını istedi
bu sefer. O zaman soru bana kütelerini
de vermiş oldu. Harika. Yerine yaz. X
için yazıyorum. X'te ne kadar bir ısı
söz konusu? Q. M'i ne kadarmış X'in? M
kadarmış. CX'i bilmiyorum. Onu soruyor.
Delta T'yi de grafikten okudum. 0'dan
4T'ye 4T kadar oldu. Bitti. Y'yi
yazıyorum. Ne kadar bir enerji verilmiş?
2 Q ku K. Kusacağım yani gerçekten. Uzun
uzun ders anlatınca da böyle oluyor. 2m
yazdım. Bana soru verdi. Öz ısısını
bilmiyorum onu istiyor. Ne kadar bir
sıcaklık değişimi var eyar yar? T'den
3T'ye 2T kadar. Artık seninle geriye
kalan basit bir matematik işlemi. Bak
Q'ları bir sadeleştireyim. M'leri bir
sadeleştireyim. T'leri bir
sadeleştireyim. Dikkat et. Burada artık
1 var değil mi? 4 ile Cx'i çarptığımda
1'e ulaştım. O zaman şuna 1/4 dersem
yani bak şuradan yazayım. 1 = 1/4 x 4
eder. Anlatabildim mi? O zaman cx
değerini yazmış olduk sevgili arkadaşım.
1/4 diye. Y için yazalım benzer bir
şekilde. Şuradaki 2 ile bu 2'yi
sadeleştirdim. Burada 1 kaldı. Burada 2
var. Bak 1 var. C var 2 var. Gördünüz
mü? O zaman CY'yi ne dersin? 1/2 dersin.
1/2 yazdın. 1/4'ü 1/2'yi oranladın. 1/4
ters çevirdin. 2/1 Gerekli
sadeleştirmeleri yaptın 1/2 gelmiş oldu.
Hocam bak her şey çok iyi gidiyordu.
Burada 1 bölüler oldu mu canım sıkıldı.
Hiç onu yapma. Ne yapalım biliyor musun?
Burada 4 var. Burada 2 2 4 var. O zaman
4'ün bir katı olarak değerlendirelim. Bu
buraya Q değil de 4Q yazayım. Buraya
şimdi 4 katını aldıysam 2Q değil 8Q
yazarım. Anlatabildim mi? Genişlettim
aslında denklemi. Şimdi takip et. Ne
kadar basit olduğunu gör. Şu yok zaten.
4 ile neyi çarparsam 4 eder? 1'i. O
zaman CX'i X'in öz hızısını 1 bulmuş
oldum. Burada 8 var. Dikkat 2 2 4 var. 4
ile neyi çarparsam 8 eder? 2'yi. O zaman
x'in öz ısısı 1, y'nin öz ısısı 2.
Cevabını yine 1/2 bulmuş olursun. Yani
arkadaşlar eğer ki burada oran orantı
yaparken yani şurayı yazarken sıkıntı
yaşamıyorsanız fizikle bir derdiniz yok
sizin. Ama benim burada yaptığım işte o
sadeleştirme işlemleri işte 1/4, 1/2
bunlarda sıkıntı yaşıyorsanız
matematikte bir sıkıntı vardır. Yani
fiziğe günah bütün günahı fiziğe
yıkmayın. Tamam mı? Fizikte bilmen
gereken şu grafiği okuyup Q = MC delta
T'yi yazabiliyor musun? Ki bence hepiniz
yaptınız, hallettiniz. İnanıyorum. Son
soru. Örnek 17. K ve L katı maddelerinin
sıcaklık zaman grafiği verildi. K ve L
özdeş ısıtıcılarla ısıtılmış olup
ısıtıcıların verdiği ısının tamamı bu
maddeler aldıysa bu niceliklerden
hangileri K ve L için kesinlikle
farklıdır? dedi. Şimdi şöyle düşün.
Ocağın üstüne bir malzemeyi koydun.
Tamam mı? Bakıyorsun 1 saat geçti.
Bakıyorsun 2 saat geçti. Özdeş ısıtıcıda
sürem ne kadar artarsa verdiğin ısı
miktarı da o kadar artar. Yani dikkat et
burada T diyor ya. Ben buna T değil ne
diyeceğim? Q. Burada 2T yani aslında
L''ye 2Q kadar enerji aktardık. Anlaştık
mı? Artık soru bitti. K için yazıyorum.
Verdiğin enerji miktarı Q. MCK yazdım.
Bilmiyorum. MKCK yazayım. Hatta
kütlesini bilmediğim için. Sıcaklık
değişimi T kadar oldu. L için yazıyorum
sevgili arkadaşım. 2Q kadar enerji
verdim. ML, Clim. Sıcaklık değişimi T
kadar oldu. Yani yani kütlelerini
bilmiyorum bu grafikte öz ısılarını
bilmiyorum. Bunlar kesinlikle farklıdır
diye bir yorum yapamıyorum ama
kesinlikle farklı olan bu ikisinin
çarpımı değerimiz neydi? Isı sığası
değeriydi. Bak Q 2Q'ya T. Bu durumda ben
buna C kadar dersem buna 2C kadar derim.
Buradan yola çıkarak ısı sığaları
kesinlikle farklı bu arkadaşların. Kabul
ettik mi? Çünkü L''nin daha fazla enerji
almasına rağmen aynı K gibi sıcaklığı
aynı miktarda değişti. Ama bu kütlesi mi
fazla olduğu için, öz ısısı mı fazla
olduğu için bilmiyorum. Isı sısı
kesinlikle fazla. O yüzden kütle ve
özısıya dair net bir şey söyleyemiyorum.
Şunu diyebilirsin hocam. K ve L farklı
maddelerse öz ısıları da kesinlikle
farklı. Haklısın ama bana kesinlikle
farklı olup olmadığını söylemedi. Bir de
kesinlik istiyorsun. O yüzden tek
söyleyebileceğin bu bilgilerden bu iki
cismin ısı sığaları yani m ve c'lerinin
çarpımları kesin farklı ama m'leri
aynıdır ama c'leri aynıdır. Buna kesin
olarak bir cevap veremedim. Dolayısıyla
cevabımı Ceyhan olarak belirlemiş oldum.
Çok güzel bir dersti. Umarım öz ısının,
ısı sırasının, sıcaklık değişiminin
nasıl birbiriyle ilişkisi olduğunu
anlatabilmişimdir. Gençler hepinizi çok
seviyorum. Böyle enerji ünitesini
neredeyse yarıladık. Sonraki konular
biraz daha afillenecek. O bölümleri de
bitirip bu üniteye beraber finito
damgamızı yapıştıracağız. Beni
dinlediğiniz için, desteklediğiniz için
her birinize çok teşekkür ediyorum. Bir
diğer derste görüşünceye kadar kendinize
iyi bakın. Hoşça kalın. Videoyu
beğenmeyi, kanala abone olmayı
unutmayın. Bay bay.
[Müzik]